la volonté de votre gouvernement de
diminuer le reste à charge sur des
prestations aussi importante que
l'optique les soins dentaires et les
prothèses auditives ne pouvait que
retenir notre attention car c'est bien
la vocation de notre mouvement que
détendre au plus grand nombre
le bénéfice de soins nécessaires et de
qualité c'est pour cette raison que nous
avons voulu contribuer activement aux
travaux
les espaces de dialogue voulu et ouvert
par madame la ministre des solidarités
et de la santé l'ont permis et je l'en
remercie
nous avons bien fait nous avons bien
fait une étude harris réalisé pour le
congrès montrent que cette réforme est
attendue par 95 % des personnes
interrogées et parallèlement pour
améliorer la lisibilité et la
compréhension de nos garanties par les
français nous avons toutes
complémentaires confondues décidé d'en
harmoniser et d'en simplifier la
présentation vous comprendrez monsieur
le président qu'il nous tarde de
connaître les arbitrages rendu ses
arbitrages conditionne le bénéfice réel
pour les français l'économie générale
des filières de soins concernés et aussi
les cotisations des mutualistes
notre deuxième thématique
c'est ce phénomène sans précédent d'une
société de villelongue qui n'a pas fini
de produire tous ses effets
l'allongement de la vie nous le
réduisons trop souvent un de ses aspects
le vieillissement mais le mouvement
mutualiste joint sa voix à tous ceux qui
y voient d'abord une excellente nouvelle
ce succès inespéré il nous dépasse tous
c'est du moins dans nos pays
la fin d'un certain pessimisme religieux
et philosophiques la fin de cette vallée
de larmes liées au non accomplissement
de la vie humaine
l'allongement de la vie a certes comme
conséquence cent mille nouvelles
personnes âgées de plus de 75 ans
parents mais aussi et je le souhaite
pour chacun de nous une augmentation
équivalente
deux jeunes de 60 ans de 65 ans de 70
ans
c'est nouvelle carrière qui commence à
50 ans ce senior qui court le marathon
ces quatre générations qui coexistent
comme jamais dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
quels changements tout invite
aujourd'hui à ne plus prendre que marc
de la vieillesse 1 h couperet mais l'âge
auquel ils restent en moyenne 15 ans à
vivre
ce qui fait qu'en un instant nous avons
tous rajeuni